a thorn fills the truth about her  relationship with Scott Disick on Monday  the 19 year old actress stopped by Jenny  McCarthy Sirius XM show and cleared up  rumors that have been swirling since May  Bella again says she and the 34 year old  are just friends I was never with them  sexually  thorn also disputed any alleged drama  between her and the Kardashian gals I'm  very friendly with Kylie and Kendall as  far as I know there's their suits chill  like I didn't have any problem with that  but she does point out how the family's  reality show seems to make Courtney's ex  the source of a lot of drama there's  always like that character that's like  you know that people beat up on a little  bit yeah and I feel like that's him on  the show at least episode Bella and  Scott have been spotted hanging out a  number of times since can we're chilling  my friends Riku  I literally just saw him so yeah like  it's all chill  [Music]